[Musique]
avec plus de 18000 spectateurs l'année
dernière le festival tout au total
s'inscrit désormais comme le rendez vous
à ne pas manquer sensibiliser le jeune
public en proposant une programmation
originale et surprenante
à voir en famille du cirque de la danse
de création locale et tout un ensemble
d'activités gratuites
le taux total répond totalement à la
mission que lui a confié le conseil
départemental ouvrir ces lieux de
culture à tous les jeunes réunionnais
dollar et donc à travers cette action
cette neuvième édition tout au total
nous sommes nous sommes vraiment en
plein dans le fait que nous travaillons
à faire découvrir à notre jeunesse les
plaisirs du théâtre les plaisirs de tout
ce qu'on peut faire de mieux en matière
culturelle nous travaillons bien sûr via
le public scolaire les écoles primaires
les collèges et lycées et nous mettons
en place un fonds de transport qui
permet justement à ces jeunes de toute
l'île de venir voir des spectacles et
nous pouvons vraiment être fier de dire
que le département aujourd'hui favorise
l'accès à la culture
deux cent mille jeunes parents faire de
l'art un tremplin pour que chaque jeune
se découvre un talent à l'image de new
graffiti ces jeunes danseurs qui sont
passés du parvis du théâtre de champ
fleuri à sa grande scène tout au total
c'est aussi un partenariat développé
entre le théâtre et plusieurs communes
de l'île mais tous les ateliers cana
dans le hall et sur le parvis les
gratuits pour tout le monde et toutes
les décentralisations qui nous affectent
les salles de liens est le plus
important c'est ça c'est un moment donné
que le papa la maman ou le danton la
tata le grand mère à qui celles-ci veut
il vient que les marmailles des cours
des spectacles et les spectacles et
dévastent la concrètement pour le
festival là il y aura du cirque
il y aura du cinéma y aura de la danse
il y aura de la musique et du conte et
du parcours free running comme il dit en
anglais avec les new gravity et le total
c'est aussi le toto kratos avec
notamment la bibliothèque éphémère et
les ateliers de la bibliothèque
départementale du 6 au 14 mars
rendez vous au théâtre de champ fleuri
[Musique]